joe biden is now the front runner and
just picked up an endorsement from
michigan's governor only days before the
state's primary and it makes sense that
michigan would love biden because it
kind of looks like a hand trying to
touch a lady's
hair with his victory eric adams will
become new york's second black mayor not
to be confused with the new york mayor
who blacks out
serena williams criticized the new york
times after it mistakenly printed a
picture of her sister venus williams and
labeled it as serena worth the times
then sent an apology letter to wendy
williams
if will smith had been expelled he would
have joined a small group of people
kicked out of the academy including bill
cosby roman polanski and harvey
weinstein or as they're also known bad
boys for life
[Music]
this week marks the 65th anniversary of
rosa parks refusing to give up her seat
on an alabama bus
and i just wish that all black people
could follow her example of sitting down
and shutting up
[Applause]
oh
thousands of what are being called penis
fish have washed up on the shore
of a california beach not only that one
kid says he even found one in his
mother's nightstand
the new york daily news published an
editorial calling for new york to
legalize marijuana saying that the
current laws primarily hurt people of
color but since it is the daily news the
headline read pot six catch niggs
went better than when i did it
[Music]
a team of doctors will soon perform a
surgery that uses muscle and skin from a
man's arm to give him a new penis which
he was born without and before the man
with no penis goes into surgery let me
just say this good luck colin now
people magazine's sexiest man alive is
dwayne the rock johnson
yeah
he once again beat his longtime rival
dwayne the scissors johnson
i am so proud of that joke
lawyers for r kelly who's being held
without bail are complaining that the
singer is only allowed to visit with one
of his girlfriends at a time
worse visiting hours conflict with the
schedule of their middle school
a restaurant in texas has created a
controversy by putting pictures of bruce
jenner on the men's room door
and caitlyn jenner on the women's room
even worse they called the handicapped
door rob
you can't do that joe
you can't do that you can't do that on
tv kamala harris will become the first
vice president to be featured as a wax
figure at madame tussauds wax museum
while joe biden is the first wax figure
to become president
amazon ceo jeff bezos claims he was
blackmailed by the publisher of the
national enquirer which he said
threatened to publish semi-nude selfies
of him and if you're curious about what
bezos penis looks like here's an
exclusive preview
for the first time in 146 years it has
not snowed in chicago during the months
of january and february or all the
snowflakes were shot before they reached
the ground
the new hbo show gilded age is being
praised for highlighting wealthy black
families that lived in new york in the
late 1800s until they were driven out by
wealthy industrialist colin jost the
first
[Applause]
so like if you go to your email you can
just like open it up it's literally
right in there
damn it this is for a sick kid
yeah very sick very sick boy okay well
here goes a mcdonald's in china was
criticized for posting a sign saying
that black people were not allowed to
enter which is the same sign i'm going
to hang on my daughter
oh my goodness
a man in oregon who had collapsed in his
house was saved after his local domino's
pizza became concerned he hadn't called
in his regular order and sent a driver
to check on him it's all part of
domino's new slogan you die when we say
you die
a 96 year old german woman who was a
secretary at a nazi concentration camp
has been released from detention she is
now safely in the custody of her
grandson
[Applause]
and grandma if you're watching go to bed
in the latest episode of gwyneth
paltrow's new netflix show sex love and
goop
a sexologist explained how people can
experience full body orgasms while fully
clothed without touching which is also
what happens when your mom watches
bridgerton
donald trump announced the launch of his
own social media network he's calling
truth social but most people know it by
its original name the national sex
offender registry
an obese monkey in thailand named
godzilla has been sent to a special
facility to lose weight
official realized the monkey was
overweight when a bunch of black guys
kept hitting on it
royal experts are saying that queen
elizabeth's health has entered a
different phase and the public may not
see her until february so you know what
that means new titties
[Music]
insiders are also saying that during
meetings president biden repeatedly uses
the f word in conversations more
concerning the f word he keeps using is
forget
ukraine president velottamir zolensky
made a televised speech during sunday's
grammy awards it was a heartfelt
impassioned plea to help the people of
ukraine but missed a
opportunity for a legendary gi jane joke
[Music]
many of the members of congress
attending the state of the union wore
blue and yellow to show their support
for ukraine while kamala harris wore all
brown to do what she's done for the last
year disappear into the background
thursday is thanksgiving and there's so
much to be thankful for this year unless
you're a human woman
justice jackson was honored friday at a
white house ceremony and said we have
come a long way toward perfecting our
union which is a direct quote from ben
affleck's proposal to jayla
there's people that love donald trump so
much that they're willing to overlook
these allegations and i can understand
that look i'm a huge fan of michael
jackson because of thriller and off the
wall but that doesn't mean i can't admit
that he's done some terrible things too
like that invincible album
or that song he made with eddie murphy
what was that it was almost as bad as
that stuff he did to those kids
president trump called justin trudeau
two-faced after the canadian prime
minister was caught making fun of trump
and it's true i've definitely seen
trudeau with at least one other face
a family in australia has discovered
what is believed to be the world's
oldest message in a bottle which was
thrown into the sea over 130 years ago
by a then middle-aged bernie sanders
this has been a tough week not to
mention we also found out 21 savage was
deported for being british which is kind
of like finding out adele is from
atlanta
21 actually had to leave the uk as a kid
probably because crazy ass liam neeson
was looking for black dudes with a
baseball bat
a woman on long island discovered a
diamond ring inside of a glove while
trying it on in a department store and
because it was long island it was still
attached to a finger
starbucks announced that starting in
2019 it will block pornography websites
over its wi-fi it's a move they're
calling chase law
that's good look fans of the hit hbo
show euphoria have been harshly
criticizing the series creator for
sexualizing the high school characters
plus it's just not accurate i mean take
it from me no one has sex in high school
a new lawsuit accuses burger king of
falsely advertising their whoppers as
bigger than what people actually get
it's the same accusation made in the
case of women versus michael che